I want to jump to the story from the
Anchorage Daily News February 3rd Alaska
National Guard plans deployment to
assist federal government on us Mexico
border I love it I posted an image of
this and someone said who knew Alaska
was so based and everyone responded
Alaska assisting the feds is not based
so the gist of the story is this they're
deploying a couple aircraft and 20
Personnel to assist with the with the
aircraft they say it's routine this is
uh they say uh major Ryan bicki a
spokesman for the US Army's Joint Task
Force North said in a phone interview
that Alaska guard members would be sent
to any of four states along the border
including Texas and Arizona Federal
requests for states to provide border
assistance are issued regularly and have
become routine now I tweeted about this
somewhat uh factiously I said what do
you call it when a National Guard is
called up to go against another State's
national guard and I got community
community noed onx where it took
selective uh excerpts from the article
to obfuscate what's actually happening
it's said they are not going against
each other I'm like I asked the question
intentionally to you know not to State
it definitively but it is true these
these individuals will be providing
assistance to CBP in Texas as well as
but that does mean Texas that does mean
part of their deployment will put them
up against Texas I don't know how else
to describe it if Texas National Guard
is saying no to CBP back the F off and
you have no jurisdiction here or we've
cut you off from your jurisdiction how
in any way could you interpret any
amount of National Guard being called in
by the feds to a variety of states which
include Texas anything other than they
will be as part of the deployment
against Texas National Guard It also
says they also said it's a routine thing
many people responded saying it's
totally routine it's not that big a deal
yo it says in the article the last time
they did this was 2019 5 years ago is
not routine no now I'm not saying Joe
Biden got on the phone and said we need
to bring the National Garden to to stop
Texas I'm saying it's a grain of sand
and a heat and the question is is this
the most toned deaf move you could
possibly make when the Texas National
Guard has deployed armed soldiers to
physically remove and bar federal agents
from removing border barriers or was it
an intentional CBP needs assistance
because of what is happening with look
I'll put it this way I don't care what
state they go to CBP and Texas are
completely at odds as to how to operate
this when we had uh we've had people who
have reported on the ground at the
border tell us when uh Taylor Hansen was
here he said tens of thousands of people
it's chaos there's litter what happened
after Texas took over three yeah he said
he said four four to six maybe and I
said thousand he goes no no no no four
to six like four five or six and I was
like you mean like on my finger for yeah
four people I'm like when what so when
CBP is facilitating human
smuggling and then Texas steps in what
do you think it's going to mean that Tex
the the the Alaska National Guard is
assisting them it means these people
these individuals who are providing SEC
assistance through with uh with Aviation
to the CBP will be at odds with the
mission of the Texas National Guard
that's a fact and I and I'll give you
one more let me see if I can find this
uh I had this I'm surprised Alaska would
send them to be honest and Dunley
because it's I mean that state kind of
already hates the FED
anyways they're like super that's like
one of the states that's actually pretty
anti-federal I had the story pulled up I
lost it but it's uh the the border
patrol Union supports the new border
bill yeah cuz they're getting yeah
there's a lot of pay increases and stuff
for Border guards there but the Border
bill as we've previously as we cover
covered in a previous segment does not
have any security at all it in it
codifies
8,500 criminal aliens entering the
country every day and gives them the
funding and it gives them more authority
to adjudicate Asylum claims without a
judge so of course they're for it do we
want let's say this law is look they're
planning on having this law probably
passed I doubt it'll happen but if it
did and CBP is now in the legal is in is
has legislatively legislatively been
given the right to bring in 5 to 8,000
criminal aliens every day and in some
instances determine their Asylum cases
just right there and they get work
permits Alaskan National Guard is going
to be helping them do that and that's
still 3 million Alle legals uh illegal
immigrants a Year by the way which is
not a huge drop in what we're seeing
currently so it's it's not it's not good
none of this is acceptable I mean it
also though I mean the the the Border
Bill also has an increase in pay for
Asylum and Border agents the that's a
big part of it so I'll point this out
too in the community note it said it has
nothing to do with operation lanar
that's exactly my point operation
lanar is Texas's operation securing the
Border this mobilization has nothing to
do with that it has to do with
supporting Customs and Border Protection
in what they do which is the opposite of
operation lonar and so they are trying
really hard to downplay this move being
being made I think we have to point this
out because Alaskan governor Mike Dunley
actually joined 24 other GOP governors
in support of Greg Abbott why now would
he be like okay I guess no no no we put
pressure on them and say don't you dare
I don't care if it's 1 five or 20 I
don't care if it's 200 we should say no
CB p is facilitating human trafficking
do not send
support yep it's all for show though did
you see what Abbott said he said that
there had been 3 to 4,000 people coming
across in a day and now it's gone down
to three yeah it's wild yeah that's what
he was that's what Taylor hansome was
telling us he's T Taylor has gone down
shout out to tenant media he reports for
tenant Taylor was saying that he he was
there during the peak of the crisis
there's garbage in thousands of people
and then once Texas takes over four
that's wild and they've move if I
understand understand correctly they
have moved the locations to places in
New Mexico and Arizona they started to
go into other states which also makes
sense for this deployment Texas look
Texas at odds with CBP they have put up
barriers in operation loone star
shipping containers with razor wire all
over them so the criminal Enterprise is
Shifting operations to other parts of
Texas New Mexico and
Arizona so what Alaska National Guard is
going to go help the human Smugglers CBP
at the border in Arizona that is still
working against this country it's worse
than just working against
Texas yeah and so like the 10th
amendment gives Texas the right to
handle their own border situation
anyways I mean at the end of the day the
Border belt would get rid of that yes
exactly that's and that's the goal I
think that's the goal because the 10th
amendment gives them the right and what
they've moved the deadline on the the
the cut off deadline from Biden what
three times now has it been like three
times they can't do anything they can't
do anything there the the the
Constitution gives Texas the right to to
B guard their own borders they could
guard their borders from any illegal
Invasion that they want to because it's
not mentioned that that power is
strictly given to the federal government
so what does the 10th Amendment say it
says that that anything not mentioned
expressly for the federal government
here in the constitution is up States
what is it article 4 section 4 states
that the federal government must defend
from Invasion sure now you got now you
got this bill that the National Guard
can respond with Le lethal force on the
border yeah but they can litigate they
canate what is an invasion all day long
for and my point is when you've got
photos and videos of uh human
traffickers with rifles to the point
where a republican has proposed a bill
that would allow the National Guard to
use lethal Force against these
individuals I'm like uh I kind of think
when they're smuggling humans with
weapons into our country and many of
them are flying the flag of their home
country and like they have guns I would
call that an invasion sure did you guys
see Brett Weinstein talk to Tucker
Carlson he went down to the Darian gap
which is this area south of I think
southern Panama between Sou dangerous
like 60 M of jungle where this is like
where most people meet their maker when
they're trying to flee here they go
through the dare I don't know most but a
lot of people die in that jungle and uh
he said he saw camps lots of camps and
they were very friendly one in
particular very friendly and they let
him in and he was talking to people
they're they're fleeing economics
they're not fleeing political Asylum
there's economic Asylum which is not US
Government first of all is not supposed
to take people for economic Asylum
that's not a real thing because it
displaces our own economics secondly
then Brett's like yo and then I went to
this camp and it was a Chinese camp and
they wouldn't let us anywhere near it
and they were what would call hostile
wow so what I think is happening is that
there is an economic migration happening
but it's masking an invasion think of it
like this I think that's I think there's
a good chance of that yeah there there's
something that people don't are that we
don't talk about or people don't bring
up much that I heard someone discussing
today was the one child policy in China
that went on from the 70s I think it was
until like just a couple years until
recently there are you know probably a
couple and I'm probably not exaggerating
but I don't know for sure but I imagine
it's probably a couple hundred million
young men that have nothing to do and no
women China needs to do something with
these guys were aborted on top of
everything else little girls were
aborted before they could be born yeah
and and so these guys young men that
have nothing to do they start civil wars
they start they cause all the problems
societies run into it's always young men
that have nothing to do and don't have
women they don't have
want to clarify we got we got a super
chat so I want to give some
clarification CU they're pointing out
that it says potentially deployed in
early 2025 I I I think it's important
that people know that but I don't think
it changes anything that we're we we're
talking about right now it's it's it's
toned deaf right now to make this
announcement and the other thing we
talked about earlier in this segment is
the point of the border security Bill uh
one strong point is that and and why
they're starting Wars they want to make
sure that whatever happens if Donald
Trump gets elected they steamroll
through what they want with without him
and lock him in place so we can't change
anything about it announcing this
deployment early means that if Trump
does get in office he'll have a harder
time stopping it from happening can we I
mean can we talk about how crazy it is
that we're bombing uh Iraq again for 33
years and we want to open the Border
completely I mean we've destabilized so
many regions in the Middle East and
we're like yeah come on in it's totally
cool no one's no one's going to worry
and and also when people come in right
we have this uh part of our culture now
is to tell everyone that America sucks
and everything that America stands for
is bad and that the culture culture
that's part of American culture right
now not my culture well that's part of
the culture of the nation in which we
were born and raised that's that has
that culture has been taken over by
really bad actors who hate America and
hate americ reolution it's a cultural
revolution and so we have people coming
in and you have all of these
progressives saying your culture is
better than ours so don't bother
assimilating don't learn English don't
learn our values don't become part of
our culture and that's not how used to
be when you had like the Ellis Island
Con you can call them who you can call
them what they are they're Communists
it's the Communists that did that you
guys love poker tables it is you will
get kicked out for speaking any other
language but English I have fun hanging
out watching you guys play poker that
had fun Yuri bof warned us of this in
the 80s I mean he defected from Russia
and said hey the Communists are taking
over every single one of your
institutions your libraries your schools
your government your hospitals all of
the for profit mental health care what
about the bank the only only but the
only reason that matters have they
overtly taken over the banks probably
yeah the only reason it matters that
they did this is that we no longer go to
church but to be fair the Communists are
taking over a lot of churches too yeah
that too I mean there's a there's a
church right street from my house saying
in a giant rainbow flag in front of the
church said what is that Liberation
theology yeah I'm like what are you guys
what are you worshiping here man I mean
this is not to West Virginia and the
churches the church I go to is full yeah
I'm a I'm like a I'm converting orthodox
currently cuz they're like the one
church that hasn't cucked to the
Communist yet do do you uh go to that
one that's like downtown
charlestone uh I don't want to say on
air
okay where you go to church at see you
there yeah there's one that every Sunday
with my child right Sheamus would go
there and uh really nice and I told the
story of how like we were going to go
grab food and Sheamus was like yeah I
got church and I'll be at it this time I
was a cool meet up and uh you know I
show up with my brother and I'm just
wearing my clothes and I see these like
little kids playing and they're dressed
very nicely and I was like
man something got lost yes you know and
it's not about in my opinion it's not
about uh being Christian and believing
in God although I think there's a strong
correlation between these things
Community is huge community and um
what's the right word I guess uh decorum
in a sense decorum Community manners
feeling like you're part of something
like the church I went to in Brooklyn
where I really liked the you know I
liked the other people there I I taught
CCD there and I liked them but they but
they um the what is what does that mean
sorry CCD CCD it's I forget what it's
called but it's basically where you
teach your teach the kids Catholicism
and they go through all the sacraments
so they start young and they go through
catechism yeah they you go through same
thing for Orthodox Church too yeah you
go through all the sacraments you have
like you know um CCD so you can get
confirmed as an adult in the church yeah
but like you do you have to do it for
orthodox chur confession and um
communion and confirmation and blah blah
blah but um it was very like there was
there was a Spanish mass that had all
the families at it and there were a ton
of kids and the whole Mass was in
Spanish and then you had the English
mass which was just a lot of old people
and hardly any kids and we don't speak
Spanish you know so much the pity I
guess and we would walk out of mass and
like all the families and kids were
coming in and like we weren't part of
that mass and I found it really
frustrating and I would say to the you
know I would say to the leadership of
the church we should do one giant
bilingual mass and parts of it are in
Spanish and parts of it are in English
and they'd be like well we won't all
understand what's going on and I'm like
we it doesn't matter if we know what's
going on or not the only thing that
matters is that my kids and your kids
are all hanging out you know trying to
get in trouble playing under the pews
that's all that matters that's what
matters and that's the only thing
they're doing to get in trouble right
that's great you know like my son
recently got in trouble because he was
at CCD and it turned out um
it turned out that he and his friend cut
Mass like they do CCD and then they have
mass and the mom my son's friend's mom
called and was very upset that the boys
had cut mass and I I'm thinking like yes
that's important they should not cut
Mass that's a problem I'm also thinking
this is great this is great like this is
what you're doing you are rebelling by
cutting Mass I am thrilled in Brooklyn
like what are you doing you're like
getting high on the street corner and
robbing people here you're cutting Mass
this is perfect big deal yeah well I'll
say this before before I move on um I
hope he's not watching tonight yeah I've
been I've been I've been uh I've been
saying this for a while you know the the
Communists the two things they have to
be at war with all the time is a strong
family unit unit and and Faith right
because when you're when you have those
strong ideals in your family or in your
church Community then it you don't just
automatically cuck to the Communist you
don't say oh we need this this
collectivism to save us right what was a
video games or TV because it was like
the 90s when things started to fall
apart because that's when people started
to go when I started to go inward I
could play a game by myself for 10 hours
alone without talking to someone I had
books before that but if I ever played
with toys like Legos or Micro Machines I
it was way better to have a second
person to play with a book obviously I
was always alone and it didn't make me
communist but video games made me very
disconnected from human and then a lot
of online games it's not about being
kind it's about like talking online
well that's what the schoolyard is too
the kids are talking the mid 2000
Call of Duty
is it video games that I don't want to I
don't think it is video games are people
disconnected it's in the schools it was
all of the stuff all of the the
socialization stuff all of the the
basically all the Socialist influence
that we have now it's all in the schools
it started in the 80s and and that was
when it first kind of took root Peggy
Macintosh is 1989 uh what's his name
paoer and and the PED what is it the
pedagogy of the oppressed and stuff all
these all this stuff became the
predominant way that that teachers learn
so this stuff got into the schools that
teach teachers so that means that every
teacher all those teachers went all over
the country so they're in Oklahoma so
these teachers these teachers are the
teachers that teach the teachers right
so you you get you get it at the very
Source you get them into an ideology
that is based on an oppression oppressor
oppressed Dynamic and you can apply that
however you want you can apply it by
race you can apply it by gender you can
apply it by any way you want but once
you get that framework into the
education of an of an entire generation
it just starts pumping out people that
are ideologically possessed that have
the same worldview which is people we it
is our job it is government's job it is
our jobs it is society's job to make
things equal and that's why you get
people that want equity you want to have
people that have uh equ equal outcomes
and that's just turns into socialism
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net